our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
last summer when thousands took to the
streets to protest the murder of george
floyd
many businesses started hanging plywood
over their windows and doors you recall
that
soon after murals appeared on the
plywood illustrating the demand for
change in one of the largest protest
movements
in american history nancy chen shows us
now how that art has found new life
and new meaning i wanted this particular
piece
to encourage little black boys when they
walked by like oh you know
i'm represented as protests filled the
streets of chicago last summer
plywood blanketing store fronts became a
canvas of sorts
for southside native bear keithley how
did this really take off
you know when people looked at all the
abandoned businesses
it was you know city-wide nationwide but
a lot of us have grown up in those
neighborhoods looking like that
the son of a police officer keithley is
also a self-taught artist
and co-created an initiative called
paint the city we had
over 60 artists during our efforts from
the north side to the west sides the
east side
south side all the sides
the art was their way to both support
the black lives matter movement
and change the city's landscape it's
definitely a moment in history
that can never be forgotten because the
manuscripts are these boards
and it's very much still ongoing we made
it our mission
to heal the city through art that
mission is taking a new form
this saturday on juneteenth the colorful
plywood that once
symbolized a closed community will go on
display
at chicago's dusable museum of african
american history
even the protesters knew not to
vandalize the artwork they just left it
alone it speaks to the cohesiveness that
not only were we doing this in chicago
but there are other people doing it
around the country in new york
sculptures created from salvaged boards
were unveiled last month as public art
in each
borough as you were looking around the
city last summer what did you see
a whole lot of plywood that's for sure
manhattan artist neil hamamoto in his
non-profit worthless studios
offered to remove plywood from
businesses for free as the
protests subsided that plywood was
just being thrown away and we were sort
of trying to come in as a solution for
them to
recycle and upcycle that material
worthless studios
selected five new york city artists for
the plywood protection project
tanda francis among them this is it this
is rocket black
you can see right here like there's
graffiti
on the piece still her 360 degree
sculpture in queens
celebrates black identity the silhouette
portrays a goddess
inspired by a rocket propelling up so
where did the idea for rocket block come
from
the work that i do is like using the
color black and and making it
known to be grand and beautiful and
a divine presence artists reshaping the
remnants of a reckoning
and telling a story in their vision what
can art do
to get people to pay attention it has
the power
for me to reach you and i don't even
have to see you
i don't even have to speak to you but
you can see a piece that any artist has
done
and you can just be moved by it for cbs
this morning nancy chen
chicago that's so true and it can
literally be a single image that can
really resonate with you and bring
something home that's why i love what
they're doing and it's so beautiful how
art can be born out of tension out of
disappointment
and those pieces were incredible that
rocket and essentially debris
you know i mean that plywood which we
all came to see and seemed to represent
how much distress there was is now a
whole symbol of hope
it is debris no more